do you live alone now are you in a
relationship with someone where where
are you at personally I'm in a
relationship with a lady that I've known
for 30 some years
um
and she's a tremendous friend I love the
life uh spending life or spending time
with her
no pressure to get married you uh
anti-marriage no I'm not anti-merge no
just not for you
um I I I I I probably will get married
is it hard for you there's an exclusive
yes it is yes it is yeah it's hard and
you haven't passed a question though yet
no
was it hard for you to open your heart
to someone
um it wasn't hard for me to open my
heart but it was hard for me to be loyal
as a man
I I cheated a lot
because uh do you think because maybe
it's a form of like I never got mine in
life I won't blame it on any excuse I
was just I just cheated
it's all pretty girl and I
tried to sleep with her
and when you're an athlete on your level
especially when they have naming candy
bars after you and everything you can
pretty much no I'm not saying you can
have every woman on the line but uh
there's a lot of women who are I won't
blame it on that either I just I just I
just won't blame it on that I had access
and and I took advantage of it and I I
missed a couple of wonderful ladies in
my life and it was my fault looking back
on your life now yes when you're older
more mature you go what the hell was I
thinking like man there was some great
women there I just didn't I did I didn't
get it
um I have a wonderful daughter
um you know and I wasn't married you
know when I had her but what an
unbelievable experience and she's given
me two grandchildren two boys
and wanted to put one of the kids the
poor son of a gun he looks just like me
yeah that ain't bad